it will be more backhauls talent must  prepare if the season pass to unlock an  exclusive mission to destroy the  guardians of the flaming eye and battle  Cylons the elite legions to earn epic  rooms test your skills in four challenge  modes game experience and rooms and  compare your victories with friends on  the online leaderboards season pass  owners unlocked every challenge mode  instantly for heads third their  domination of Mordor time to go on gain  new skills and unique epic rooms as you  hunt and tame legendary monsters of  Mordor and he's all new story missions  players Kella bring more great elven  King of the second age and wield a ring  of power to face the Dark Lord Sauron  himself I like it